we did it Reddit Nvidia was so
embarrassed by the specs of the RTX 480
12 gig that they unlaunched it and now
in its place we've got the RTX 470 TI
it's it's the same GPU but with a
different name oh but it got a $100
price drop which unfortunately isn't
quite the double that you might think it
is while theoretically there will be 47
ETI for $700
there are no first party Founders
edition cards meaning that that MSRP is
really just that a manufacturers
suggested retail price and later we're
going to get into why no one really
follows nvidia's suggestions anymore the
card that we were sent for review for
example is lightly overclocked and costs
$850 meaning that I kind of have to
evaluate this as a 40802 gig with a name
change and a
5.5%
discount this thing better be
amazing amazing like our sponsor Ridge
wallet Ridge wallet has redefined the
traditional wallet with its compact
frame and RFID blocking plates keep your
wallet bulge down and use our offer code
Linus to save 10% and get free worldwide
shipping
[Music]
right out of the gate the 4070 TI is in
trouble with specs that I might have
imagined on a 4070 or even a 4060 super
that puts its total bandwidth somewhere
in between the RTX 3070 and 370 ti so
its only chance is if its other specs
can pick up the slack fortunately on
paper the 470 TI's core performance
should contribute to a sizable uplift it
has 25% more Cuda course than its
predecessor and they're clocked
substantially higher that's a good sign
even before the architectural
improvements thanks to its adal love La
cores this means improved Ray tracing
and tensor cores and Shader execution
reordering which optimizes the order of
the data sent to the ray tracing cores
Nvidia called this as big an innovation
for gpus as outof order execution was
for CPUs though if our recent poll is
any indication most of you won't be
making use of it anytime soon of course
how would you given the ongoing
popularity of the 10 series gpus which
are turning 7 years old this year
nvidia's marketing push for the 470 TI
is that it makes for a great upgrade
from 10 and 20 series gpus which okay
Nvidia let's play along with that for a
moment compared to the GTX 1080 and 1080
TI at 4K we are looking at a staggering
two to three times Improvement in Shadow
of the Tomb Raider taking us from sub 60
FPS averages to over a 100 Modern
Warfare 2 is even more impressive at up
to 4 and 1 half times the performance
we're talking cinematic to playable just
like that 1440p does give our 10 series
cards a better chance but we're still
looking at two to four times the
performance in both of these games
making this truly an incredible upgrade
over the 10 series GP no no no no this
is stupid I don't need to spend $850 to
upgrade a 7-year-old card Ah that's
better to see how it really competes we
tested the RTX 470 TI not against what
Nvidia wants but against a truly
intimidating stack of gpus as an FYI
even though our review was so recent we
sanity checked our RX 7000 series GPU
results since driver updates have
actually changed their performance
characteristics since launch we've also
revalidated any of the numbers that
we've reused and we'll talk a bit more
about our plans for our GPU testing
methodology in a future video even with
the full lineup shadow of the Tomb
Raider has the 47 ETI within about 8% of
the RTX 3090 TI which is a fairly
impressive achievement considering that
it is nominally a 70 series GPU what's
more impressive though is that it gets
handily beat by the RX 7900 XT yes yes
I'm aware that that GPU costs $50 more
but it's the beginning of a pattern that
repeats itself first in F1 2022 where
the the 470 TI gets stomped well beyond
what that price difference would suggest
starting the 470 TI off on pretty Rocky
ground Hitman 3 continues this
floundering performance with frame rates
nearly on par with the 3090 TI but well
off of AMD and the RTX 480 that it used
to share a name with and it's really
more of the same story with Red Dead
Redemption 2 Assassin's Creed valala
Modern Warfare 2 and cyberpunk though
cyberpunk is more of a beat down thing
to that game's memory hungry nature we
think thankfully for NVIDIA Forza
Horizon 5 gives the 470 TI some
breathing room as it meets or beats the
7900 XT and even beats the 3090 TI
though it's still a good 133% off of the
real 4080 it's a really good thing that
they changed that naming for 4K gaming
then the RTX 4070 TI ends up firmly
behind both of amd's Radeon 7000 series
and everything from Nvidia from the 3090
TI and up which seems to suggest that
Nvidia basically looked at 3090 TI
pricing on eBay and said hm about like
that sounds good maybe things will look
a bit better at
1440p and they kind of do now that
memory bandwidth is less of an issue
shadow of the Tomb Raider sees the 470
TI pull ahead of the 390 TI and close
the gap on its bigger siblings though it
still falls behind AMD if only slightly
Hitman sees the 47 ETI backsliding a
little in relation to the 7900 XT while
maintaining its performance improvement
over the 3090 TI but this doesn't carry
over into cyberpunk Modern Warfare 2 and
Assassin's Creed valhala where we're
looking at pretty much the same relative
performance as our 4K tests Forza
however picks up spectacularly with the
47 ETI sitting firmly in third place
contributing to a generally Rosier
picture at 1440p overall with roughly
equal performance to a 3090 TI and a
small enough Gap from the 7900 XT it
looks almost compelling in this
overpriced GPU hellscape and that's
before we turn on Ray tracing which
works fine right I mean we knew it would
be superior to the 7900 XT since that's
a stronghold for NVIDIA at this point
but what was surprising is that it
wasn't by as much as we expected I was
shocked to see the 7900 XTX actually
outperform it at 4K in everything except
for cyberpunk where the rate tracing
course seemed to be doing a better job
potentially thanks to SC at 1440p things
again get a bit better for the 470 TI
with only a mild loss against the 7900
XTX in Shadow of the Tomb Raider and
overall better performance in the rest
of the suite cyberpunk hits AMD even
harder here but that doesn't help the
470 TI against its own brothers who pull
away significantly that weak memory
bandwidth seems to be really holding it
back here interestingly when we turned
on dlss 3.0 to test if the 470 TI's
diminished tensor core count would
prevent it from keeping up it did just
fine in cyberpunk with a similar
performance uplift to the 4080 and the
4090 but then we did not see the same
thing in
f-122 we tried a bunch of different
settings here and nothing we did change
the outcome at all we think this could
be a driver issue considering that
cyberpunk of all games is fine so we've
reached out to Nvidia about it to see
what they have to say say if they
respond in time for this video we'll
have their response on screen right now
um and I'll just use this time to tell
you all about how delicious water tastes
from your LTD store.com water bottle
it's great in rate tracing then the 470
TI is looking a lot like an RTX 39 DTI
when we look at the overall picture and
as expected rate tracing performance for
the price is superior to anything from
team red unfortunately for NVIDIA the
vast majority of our viewers have never
once enabled r retracing and under 15%
of you actively use it so at least for
you guys it might not be the trump card
that they were hoping it would be what
might be though is productivity because
remember as much as we like to talk
about games these gpus for a lot of
people end up used for work too starting
with nvidia's current Ace in theole
blender the 470 TI manages a solid 43%
improvement over its predecessor but
falls behind the RTX 30 390 TI and
especially the RTX 4080 with performance
against the latter being a mostly linear
relationship with the difference in Ray
tracing core count things pick up a
little with proon with the video editing
Suite giving the 470 TI very close
performance against the 39 DTI though
still slightly behind both radon 7000
series cards photo editing is
interesting however most of the results
are within a couple of percentage points
which seems to suggest that any modern
GPU will be sufficient but this doesn't
tell the whole story as more machine
learning effects and filters trickle
into your workflow you can expect to see
these numbers change and it could be a
pretty solid Advantage for NVIDIA Da
Vinci resolve gives the 470 TI and Bank
encoders a run for their money with what
looks to be a memory bandwidth
bottleneck slowing it down considerably
next to its bigger siblings it manages
to be a little bit faster than its
bandwidth difference would suggest but
this unfortunately means that out of our
test Suite it only really beats the RTX
36 60 in export speed topaz AI though is
a better story for the 470 TI where its
enhanced core architecture makes shorter
work of this GP GPU workload than even
the RTX 390 TI though AMD is the one who
ends up stealing the show here with even
the last gen 6900 XT putting up
comparable numbers the spec Suites are
another strong suit for NVIDIA ever
since the 20 series and the RTX 470 TI
trades blows with the 390 TI in a lot of
these tests which is a good thing
unfortunately though there are cases
like 3ds Max and solid works that give
the 470 TI some trouble likely again
thanks to its relative shortage of cores
and limited memory bandwidth however
energy and medical end up being standout
wins for the 470 TI and in all cases
it's substantially faster than the RTX
380 let alone the 370 TI that ignores
AMD of course though whose cards all
spank it across the board with the
exception of 3ds Max Seaman NX as usual
will be ignored in our final performance
Tellies since this version is old enough
to not have proper support for NVIDIA
gpus but we're putting the data in here
in case you're interested finally the
470 TI outperforms the RTX 390 TI in
every part of spec workstation although
as with vew perf AMD maintains big wins
over all of nvidia's cards across most
of the suite with the exceptions of
median entertainment and GPU compute so
much for that stronghold overall
performance looks like a 3090 TI but at
a lower cost and hopefully a lower power
draw but it really does depend on what
you're doing if you're into 3D rendering
or GPU compute you're going to get a lot
more bang out of a 4070 TI than the 3090
TI which could make it an attractive
option for the price and hopefully the
power draw if you're into video editing
however it's not a worthy upgrade over
even the 3070 TI and you might want to
consider a 7,000 series Radeon instead
if you need a new GPU today preferably
one with Hardware av1 encoding support
so if we're looking at an RTX 390 or 390
TI equivalent here surely the 470 TI
should be more energy efficient too well
in MSI combuster it pulled the lowest
out of not only the 40 series family but
also when compared to amd's price
competitors hovering at around 280 Watts
most of the time and never breaking past
its 285 watt rating when we switch to a
more real world test f-122 the story
stays pretty much the same this time
with the card hovering at around 275
Watts that is well within spec even
though our card is a factory overclocked
model it's worth noting by the way guys
that in our Radeon RX 7900 series review
we made a mistake when we changed the
way that we collected our data and we
initially showed total Graphics power
and total board power in the same chart
those measurements are not comparable so
this time we are strictly using total
board power and in the future we're
planning to use external equipment for
better accuracy than board sensor
or nvidia's pcap stay tuned for that
when we zoom in on our power consumption
results for fortza Horizon 5 at 1440p
the power consumption without a frame
rate cap is pretty much in line with the
RTX 480 which actually is not a great
thing considering that it ran about 5 to
10 FPS slower however when we cap the
frame rate to 100 it actually lines up
so perfectly I almost thought the graph
only had three lines amd's cards by
comparison ran about 30 to 50 Watts
higher most of the time that works out
to about 17 watts per frame less than
the radon 7900 XT when it's uncapped and
a good 35 Watts when capped not a bad
efficiency story and no high idle power
consumption bugs when connected to
different monitors like we saw with
amd's 7000 series now thermals are going
to be a difficult conversation since
there isn't a like a reference or a
Founders edition of the RTX 470 TI with
a standard cooler for us to test with
that in mind then take these results
with a grain of salt starting with
combuster it's not looking great for our
tough OC edition of the 470 TI which
quickly ramps up past 80° and holds
there throughout our run this is well
above the RTX 480 with its Founders
cooler and More in line with the 490
f-122 pushes the 470 TI even higher
relative to the 490 sticking again to
around the 80° Mark to be clear this
isn't the end of the world as long as
the core clocks are high and stable at
these temperatures and high they
probably will be I suspect that the only
470 TI that you will find readily
available at launch will be Factory
overclocked like ours which managed
among the highest clocks that we've ever
seen on a GPU even though it can't
maintain full boosting combuster and has
a little bit more wobble than the RTX
480 it's worth saying again though that
your mileage will vary depending on a
given cards cooling setup and vbios
f-122 is a more realistic load and sees
that variation calm down a bit with the
470 TI with it regularly hitting our
Factory overclocked cards 2.7 GHz boost
clock but again your mileage may vary
once the first summer heat wave strikes
because as you guys saw we're flying
pretty close to the Sun on our thermals
and that's in a temperature controlled
room as the saying goes there's no such
thing as a bad product only a bad price
so so it's time to talk about that
originally announced at $900 as the RTX
4802 gig the current starting price now
that it is the 47 ETI is
$800 that's $100 less but not only is
that $200 higher than the RTX 370 TI
MSRP was at launch that price only
barely puts it in a competitive position
against the Radeon RX 7900 XT in typical
raster gaming and it's not even
guaranteed to net you 60 FPS if you do
turn on rate tracing making some flavor
of dlss a necessity unless you want to
dial back the settings on an
$850 card it's still a lot For What by
its name should be a high mid-range GPU
not a step down Enthusiast class one so
how does Nvidia justify its astronomical
price tag for a 70 series GPU that as we
said before really seems more like a 60
super to put it bluntly they don't and
as far as they're concerned they
shouldn't have to I mean you think they
renamed the RTX 470 TI out of the
goodness of their hearts and it was a
big win no up until literally just last
week it was still up in the air whether
Nvidia would drop the price at all
compared to the announced $900 price for
the RTX 4802 gig it took their business
partners begging and pleading with them
to make that happen and that was in
spite of the reportedly atrocious sales
figures for the RTX 480 and the radon
7900 xt's existence at that very same
price point it's good they yielded but
they still have more work to do Invidia
reportedly offered Partners some
compensation for the work involved in
the rebranding but at this point we
haven't heard confirmation that they
intend to do the same for this new
MSRP that means that if this chart
showing the meager scraps of margin that
Nvidia leads for its Partners is to be
believed any MSRP cards that you see are
going to be very limited in stock and
essentially just for show so that media
like us will be suckers and talk about
how this card is$
799 board makers like any other business
are not going to go out of their way to
lose money if Nvidia hasn't adjusted the
pricing asus's top end stricks 470 TI
then is just $150 less than a 480
Founders Edition making even that card
look good by comparison reports from
Asus suggest that the tough OC will be
the most plentiful skew but from
conversations we've had with Memory
Express here in Canada that's actually
been the opposite for the rest of the 40
series lineup where almost no tough
cards exist so what it looks like is
NVIDIA is pointing at the price saying
but it can't be expensive we set it at
$799 see but the partners have
absolutely no way of achieving that in
the real world
I'm having a hard time figuring out
nvidia's game here to be honest with you
the GPU Market has reportedly hit a
20year sales low thanks to a combination
of high prices the mining crash and
extenuating economic circumstances and
yet Nvidia seems determined to pour
water on the fire expecting a huge
premium even on products in the high SL
mid tier of their product stag I mean
don't forget as much as we focus on
desktop gpus and PC gaming on this
channel the real competition for a card
like this could easily be an Xbox or a
PlayStation 5 either of which would
frankly be a much more compelling value
to the average gamer and I feel like
Nvidia if they don't turn things around
is at risk of losing PC gaming customers
long term to the console side it's
starting to almost look like a a
microsof Ian good bad good cycle that
they've been on for the last few years
here 10 series was great 20 series was a
that fart 30 series kickstarted a whole
new generation of PC gamers in spite of
the pandemic price hikes and as product
development Cycles run for longer and
longer with each new generation the
impact of this kind of please people 50%
of the time piss them off 50% of the
time starts to become more dramatic and
Nvidia clearly hasn't learned their
lesson yet I mean apple and Tesla have
proven that people will still buy your
product even if you treat them badly but
that only holds true if you have the
absolute best products on the market it
doesn't build loyalty so this strategy
around the 4070 TI and especially the
480 clearly isn't it for the long term
it is time for NVIDIA to focus on
squeezing out margins less and
delighting customers more now AMD Is Not
Innocent here to be clear while the RX
7900 series is a better value than the
4080 the 4070 TI is content to price
itself right in line with its
performance against the 7900 XT a card
that also should probably be more like
$700 considering its 80 class
performance level Nvidia enabled AMD
then to charge more themselves through
their own astronomical pricing and AMD
is in turn enabling Nvidia to normalize
those prices by providing a comparably
fair price on this step down product
which Nvidia can then compete with as
they both run down the stack as long as
this continues and as long as Nvidia
keeps trying to kill Moore's law in the
collective Consciousness things are
never going to change nowhere is this
attitude more apparent than nvidia's
positioning for the RTX 470 TI not as
competition for AMD or even against a 30
series card but as an upgrade from 20
series and 10 series gpus and I mean yes
it is an upgrade but it would also be an
upgrade over a toaster or a lital potato
especially if that potato is 7 years old
I mean even an arc GPU would be an
upgrade over a 10 series most of the
time so like what's your point
Nvidia final word then it's a good
product at a bad price from a company
that is failing more and more to hide
its ugly nature you're going to buy it
you always do and you know what you'll
probably be happy with it but I don't
have to be happy about that what I am
happy to tell you about is our sponsor
Jacker jackary makes solar ready
portable power stations designed to
improve outdoor Life by providing power
Outdoors whenever and wherever you need
it before they used to use maple syrup
for that their new solar generator 1000
Pro is their fastest solar and wall
recharging generator yet boasting three
times faster charging than the normal
sg1000 it consists of a jackary Explorer
1000 Pro portable power station and 80 W
solar panels plug it into the wall and
get a full charge in under 2 hours and
deliver up to 100 watts of power thanks
to to the new 100 wat power delivery
ports so check out the new jackary solar
generator 1000 pro at the link below if
you guys enjoyed this video go check out
our review of the radon 7000 series for
a little more on what Nvidia is up
against this generation AMD seems to be
catching up slowly but surely even if um
they too cost a fortune